bonjour et bienvenue dans les sept huit
week-ends l'émission consacrée aux
loisirs aux idées de sorties dans le
département tout de suite le sommaire de
votre magazine sport le centre verticale
art situé dans la zone d'activités du
pas du lac à montigny-le-bretonneux
organise une compétition d'escaladé ce
samedi vous recevront dans quelques
instants le cogérant kenny cajigas pour
qu'il nous parle de ces épreuves
exposition nous allons prendre la
direction de guyancourt dans cette
émission l'exposition être au monde est
programmée actuellement dans la ville
saint-quentinoise
l'événement est organisé jusqu'au 29 mai
par l'association rémanence les détails
dans ce magazine nous parlerons
également de la 13e édition des
prairiales de montigny le bretonneux la
fête des fleurs et des jardins
programmées ce week-end à la ferme du
manège et puis coup de projecteur sur
les programmations dans les salles
obscures nous prendront la direction du
ciné 7 d'elancourt luc beaucamps englos
le responsable nous présentera son coup
de coeur on commence ce magazine par un
rendez-vous le centre verticale art
situé dans la zone d'activités du pas du
lac à montier bretonneux organise une
compétition à d'escaladé ce samedi à
partir de 14h pour nous parler de cette
journée nous recevons sur ce plateau le
cogérant kenny cajigas bonjour jours
alors pourquoi organiser cette journée
de compétition alors il est baptisé
verticale attaque alors on a eu
l'occasion de d'agrandir notre salle
comme on vous l'avait précisé déjà il ya
quelques mois et en fait on a pour
l'inauguration voulu faire une
compétition pour tous les gens soient
motivés et vienne et sait on
en gros nos nouveaux blocs le nouveau
mur d'escaladé on attend à peu près
entre 200 et 300 personnes donc sur une
journée complète on ouvrait à midi on
fermera à 21h sauf si des motivés sont
continuer à faire la fête mais voilà en
gros on compare sur une complétion
standard sur des qualifications avec
certains blogs des finales des remises
de prix des petits concours des petites
animations entre les différentes étapes
et ensuite on part sur une soirée type
électro comme on le fait d'habitude
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce que les gens soient
me plus motivés les niveau sera relevé
alors là on est sur un niveau on est
sont tous niveaux en fait un an qu'on
peu n'importe qui peut venir s'inscrire
le moindre débutants jusqu'à déjà un
petit peu plus confirmé donc vraiment
c'est une confession ouvert à tout le
monde allait elle n'est pas spécialement
réservé aux gros niveau
et comment fait on pour son frère justin
suffit de venir samedi matin à midi
entre 12h et 13h on a les inscriptions
vous venez alors pour ceux qu'on doit
des abonnements qui sont déjà abonnés
vie enfin et c'est gratuit
ensuite c'est une séance le prix d'une
séance normale pour quelqu'un qui vient
pour la première fois ou qui vient de
manière ponctuelle à la salle et ensuite
une fois 13h lesquels les qualifications
commencent jusqu'à 17h ou là on aura une
petite pause avec un petit tapis hour
une petite ou une ou deux petites
activités concours avec des lots à
gagner et derrière on enchaîne sur les
finales être là la remise des lots vers
vers 21h et donc c'est finalement pour
tous niveaux
tous n'y a pas besoin d'avoir à un
niveau très voulons absolument pas un an
là on est vraiment sur une compétition
ouvert à tout le monde même quelqu'un
qui commence l'escaladent peut venir se
confrontaient peut venir se se battre et
s'amuser un petit peu avec ses collègues
ou amis des personnes inconnues et alors
il arrivera peut-être pas 1er mai il a
de quoi ses muses et cet événement
s'accompagne également de l'inauguration
c est rigolo n'y sommes exactement
figuration donc on devient une des plus
grandes salles d'île de france avec un
bloc c'était un mur d'escaladé qui sort
un peu de de tout ce qu'on voit
d'habitude qui est une forme vraiment
qui n'existe pas à part chez nous qui a
beaucoup fait parler d'elle
c'est pour ça qu'on attend vraiment
vraiment beaucoup de monde demain c'est
pourquoi avoir décidé d'agrandir cette
structure a le double elle double ou en
double la surface même un petit peu plus
tout simplement ce que deux ans on
arrivait déjà saturation
on arrivait des soirs où la salle était
pleine ne pouvait plus accueillir du
monde donc on a eu l'occasion d'acheter
ce bâtiment à côté et de casser les murs
est vraiment là de doubler la surface
pourrait déjà avoir plus de choix
le type d escalade mais aussi la demande
est trop petit beaucoup trop petit alors
que la voilà maintenant on est sur
quelque chose de très spacieux très aéré
vraiment très confortable et les
grimpeurs attendent vraiment que ça
depuis depuis plusieurs mois et pour
l'instant personne n'a la tester non
pour l'instant est on est on a mis des
rubalises tous les blocs sont ouverts
prêts à accueillir les grimpeurs toutes
numérotées pour la compétition et les
jambes un petit peu de vent devant cette
vitrine en fait et attendre qu'une chose
c'est franchir le franchir la barrière
et si on n'est pas dans le concours on
peut quand même venir à six nations il
n'y a pas de souci nous à chaque fois
qu'on fait un concours on ouvre les
portes à n'importe quel curieux donc ou
n'importe quelle personne peut venir
grimper sans s'inscrire au concours sel
ne le souhaite pas et c'est un événement
unique à one shot où il y aura d'autres
événements de ce type dans les
prochaines semaines prochains mois
prochain non ce type d'événement on en
fait plusieurs années par contre on aura
un autre événement là qui est d'une
ampleur beaucoup plus importante
le 18 juin pardon avec la vraiment de
l'argent à gagner un cash prize
on attend les meilleurs mondiaux
des gens comme allemand levier enfin
plusieurs personnes de l'équipe de
france
et tous les motivés pour qu'ils sont
prêts à se battre pour pour ce podium
avec de l'argent la clé et en plus de ça
en parallèle on fera une compétition
plus on va dire amateurs pour vraiment
canet pour gagner pour tout le monde on
attend à peu près 600 700 personnes avec
vraiment des des stands avec différents
marque d'escale à différents
fournisseurs vraiment quelque chose de
très très gros qui s'est jamais fait
donc une salle d'escaladé - vitres à
cette occasion eh bien merci à vous
d'être passé sur ce plateau je rappelle
l'événement en vertical attaque est
programmée ce samedi 23 avril au centre
verticale art
on passa deux autres rendez vous sports
avant de refermer cette rubrique en
handball le chesnay reçoit sur son
terrain chartres à l'occasion de la 19e
journée du championnat de nationale 3
nationale 2 pardon avant dernier du
classement l'échiné siens doivent
l'emporter pour espérer se maintenir
charte occupe de son côté la 8e place du
championnat
si vous voulez les soutenir le match est
programmé au gymnase de nouvelle france
samedi à 19h
on passe au rugby on jouera ce dimanche
la dernière journée du championnat de
fédérale 3 chevreuse dernier du
classement recevra sur sa pelouse
châteauroux au stade municipal dimanche
à 15 heures plus de 300 spectateurs
devraient venir encourager les
chevrotins pour ce match à quitte ou
double je veux ce compte sur sa défense
pour remporter à la victoire
après le sport on passe à notre rubrique
exposition
nous allons prendre à présent la
direction de guyancourt dans cette
émission l'exposition être au monde est
programmée actuellement dans la vie la
saint-quentinoise l'événement est
organisé jusqu'au 29 mai par
l'association rémanence un reportage de
sephora namani et de camille lambert
questionner le rapport de l'humanité à
la nature réfléchir sur la condition de
l'homme dans une époque en pleine
mutation
c'est le projet de l'association
rémanence créer en 2012 par les artistes
jérôme delépine et eric bourguignon un
projet articulé autour d'une première
exposition en 2014 sur la jeunesse du
monde et d'une deuxième présentée
actuellement à lui en cours intitulé
être au monde rémanence est une
association d'artistes qui propose en
fait des regards entre ses oeuvres
d'artistes entre figuration et
abstraction je dirais avec une vraiment
une proposition assez inédite assez
originale de mettre en regard leurs
propres oeuvres avec des oeuvres
d'artistes qui ne sont plus de ce monde
un rapport au monde questionné par ces
artistes plasticiens au moyen de
peintures à l'huile des saints au
graphite sculptures en bronze et en cire
ou encore photographie argentique pour
exprimer un regard humaniste voire
existentialiste l'aspect figuratif du
corps de tradition classique se font
dans une abstraction plus modernes pour
que sur la toile les silhouettes
apparaissent et disparaissent
il ya vraiment ce jeu entre le corps
l'humanité qui peut-être enveloppé voir
et tout fait part par cette nature on
peut on penser de loin qu'il ya vraiment
une simple abstraction des masses de
couleurs mais en s'approchant on voit
apparaître des petites formes humaines
des petits personnages qui grouillent
vraiment dans l'espace de la toile
le projet de l'association de rémanence
sous clôturera avec une troisième
exposition en 2018 sur la peur et
l'espérance sur le même thème une
exposition de peinture a été lancée à
promo paul à montils bretonneux baptisé
la coursive des talents l'événement
regroupe une quarantaine d'oeuvres pour
nous parler de ce rendez-vous nous
recevons sur ce plateau stéphane dumouch
initiateur de la coursive des talents et
l'artiste yves montand à pascal à la
cire bonjour je alors quel est
l'objectif de cette exposition
bon ben c'est de se faire plaisir déjà
entre personnes qui ont un certain goût
pour l'art artistes qui ont envie de
montrer leurs oeuvres ou artistes qui
ont envie de montrer l'oeuvre de leur
ami joël cunin qui vient du nord
artiste assez réputé ancien postier qui
a été contacté par pascal pour mettre en
place cette exposition donc avec cet
artiste et artistes autre artiste de la
poste locaux ou non locaux ile-de-france
ou montigny comme montigny comme pascal
et donc on a joint moi c'est cette
artistique de la poste pour pour
englober tout ça pour se préparer dès
pour préparer les flyers les invitations
l'affichage tulle elle aimait les mici
mais c'était surtout pour promouvoir mon
ami qui a beaucoup de succès dans le
nord le faire connaître dans la région
ile de france
mais pourquoi avoir choisi promo paul en
particulier promo paul c'est une
rencontre avec stéphane justement qui
m'a présenté l'endroit et je trouvais
que c'était l'art qui s'immisçait un peu
dans l'industrie et avec cette cour si
cette verrière cette lumière naturelle
ça ça correspondait parfaitement à
arette pour une exposition
cette femme vous confirmer c'est le lieu
idéal pour oui parce que quand j'ai
découvert ce j'étais en réunion
le président l'astre hoa thomas nast
rookie présidente trop molle du conseil
d'administration de promeo paul et j'ai
vu ce lieu qui était vide blanc très
lumineux et je me suis dit tiens il ya
peut-être moyen de faire une exposition
alors comme othman est quand même
quelqu'un de très bienveillant voir
quelqu'un de très délicat il a tout de
suite donné son accord il a donné son
feu vert
et donc on s'est lancé dans cette
aventure en contactant les différents
amis que qui tournait autour de la ou de
la création artistique parce qu'elles
assiègent quel tableau peut-on retrouver
dans cette actualisation gym et une
dizaine de tableaux et notamment
l'africaine miroir on on vient de voir
des images et
j'ai mis en fait je peins beaucoup mes
états d'âme à travers des poses de
femmes
c'est un petit univers secret et voilà
donc on peut découvrir aussi dans cette
exposition et c'est une exposition
personnelle non anglais n'ont alors que
mon exposition c'est un petit peu dans
l'exposition océan là ont vraiment fait
tant dans le but aussi de faire
connaître
joël cunin carpe et un sociétaire et la
société artistique parce que pour moi
c'est un grand exemple on voit jean
lartigue qui fait des choses très
particulière des boîtes à rue donc c'est
des oeuvres en 3d qui touche beaucoup
les gens donc à des oeuvres un peu plus
classique et joël qaîda nous a amenés
plein de choses différentes des
portraits des portraits paysages des
danseuses avec la nouvelle des paysages
dont c'est une exposition assez riche
assez riche est assez diversifié on
voulait pas se lancer sur un thème on
voulait montrer un maximum de choses
voilà vous deviez arrêté l'exposition le
20 avril finalement c'est bon mangez
jusqu'au 26 louis à l'ordre tout
simplement parce qu'on voulait pas
arrêter l'émission sans être passés à
telus 78 pour parler d'une chose qui
nous a plu et partager tout ça non plus
sérieusement c'est parce que il ya une
demande
visiblement ça a créé qu'elle une
émulation une envie et et donc on a
poussé jusqu'au bout du bout en fonction
de la disponibilité des artistes que ce
soit du côté de la poste ou de rendre ce
soit du côté de monsieur aucune rascal
elles sont un très bon retour voilà on
s'est dit pourquoi location les retours
justement sur cette exposition vous
allez leur tour souvenue très positif
vraiment ben peu médiatique quelques
ventes
et puis le fait enfin je sais pas c'est
surtout simple délit rencontre avec le
personnel de promo paul les sociétaires
de propofol qui dit dans des résidences
pour nos pas là pour qui ces voix là on
a ramené de la chaleur des couleurs de
la vie on a senti une émulation par
rapport à tout ça et vous voilà le fait
de continuer je sais qu'ils vont
regretter quand il y aura plus ça mais
bon donc on va peut-être ont commencé je
sais pas mais en tout cas il ya une
demande pour recommencer effectivement
la prochaine exposition se fera à promo
pâle ou peut-être dans une autre alors
partie de la fin une autre ville
saint-quentinoise par exemple bah on a
quelques idées
enfin je sais qu'avec pascal on a des
vaincus à des projets bientôt tu va
exposer au salon de montigny autour du
conservatoire servent à terre des arts
du conservatoire des arts
tu as aussi déposer ou tu va déposer un
dossier pour exposer à la maison félix
après au tour de promo à proprement dit
oui il ya des choses en l'air mais bon
c'est pas encore ça pas de projet
concret il n'y a pas de projet concret
il ya des idées il n'y a pas de projet
concret l'airé l'idée peut-être de faire
une galerie permanente
pourquoi pas bon après la première fois
il ya des idées comme ça mais c'est à
creuser c'est pas encore confirmé en
tant qu'appareil et c'est pas qu'on
prenne il n'y a pas de encore une fois
la bienveillance d'autres manas où nous
donne envie de faire des choses
voilà merci à tous les deux ans quand
même passé nazi je voulais surtout en
facile si votre mana seront et son
personnel et madame il est madame
michèle pas par l'accueil est vraiment
juste avant quitté le plateau rappeler
deux secondes dimanche
c'est il ya un accès exceptionnel de 14
heures à 18 heures pour les personnes
qui n'ont pas pu venir en semaine les
horaires qui sont liées à l'exercice de
promo donc 14h 18h et vous êtes bienvenu
non pas aux journalistes avec monsieur
richie la rédaction mais en tant que
personne c'est notre agenda en tout cas
merci à tous les dettes passées sur ce
plateau je le rappelle était spectateur
donc l'événement programmé jusqu'à ce
mardi 26 avril à provo paul merci à vous
on passe maintenant à notre rubrique
littérature
direction à présent le pavé du canal
comme chaque semaine a les bras et vous
fait découvrir un nouveau roman
cette semaine zoom sur jardin de
dissidence de johnatan laisse m paru aux
éditions de l'olivier un livre sur
l'histoire de new york
écoutez je vais te présenter les jardins
de la dissidence de jonathan nelson qui
est une
un passage en revue de toute la vie
américaine des années 50 a de nos jours
surtout le monde de dissidence est un
peu d'insurgés a new yorkaise alors
c'est vraiment centralisé sur un sur un
quartier propre de new york qui est dans
le queens et donc dans le nord-est et
donc on va passer en revue et la
grand-mère qui est qui a eu un passé de
communistes vraiment très active qui
s'est fait virer du parti communiste
parce que elle couchait avec un noir
ensuite donc il ya sa fille qui prend le
relais qui vide les années 70 comme new
york a pu vivre aux années 70 et son
petit-fils donc on arrive jusqu'à
occuper wall street
et donc voilà donc on passe en revue
tous ces mouvements interculturel qui
ont pu avoir lieu
surtout new york et on n'apprend pas
découvert des choses sur la vie
politique de new york enfin des choses
que tu connaissais pas du tout dans son
lit alors ouais c'est ça en fait tu
découvres amont que ces mouvements avait
il y avait du monde qu'enfin il y avait
un vrai terreau propice à tous cette
révolte là et que c'était plutôt bien
organisé et que voilà qu'il y avait une
vraie vie aussi artistique alors cette
vision un peu culturelle et politique de
la vie new yorkaise et toutes les contre
cultures qui existait aussi par ailleurs
donc ouais on apprend pas mal de choses
alors même s'il paraît un peu épais
comme ça vraiment ça passe comme un
souffle et c'est une histoire très
haletant qui nous emmène jusqu'à la fin
d'accord c'est une histoire des etats
unis en fait vu par une seule famille et
c'est une épopée voilà c'est un roman
chorale qui vit pendant 50 ans fin qui
passe en revue 50 ans de la vie de la
contre culture américaine
un rendez-vous à ne pas manquer pour les
amateurs de jardinage la 13e édition des
prairiales est programmée à ce week-end
à la ferme du manet de montigny le
bretonneux pour nous parler de cet
événement nous recevons sur ce plateau à
la aubry et le commissaire général de
l'après real bonjour bonjour alors quel
sera le programme cette année bien au
bout de 13 ans c'est quand même la
continuité mais il y aura dans la
tradition dans la tradition il y aura 55
exposants dont plus de la moitié dans
les métiers du jardin qui viendront
proposer leurs plantes ou leurs services
aux habitants de la région
il ya des nouveautés il y as we des
nouveautés il ya 50 % à peu près de
nouveau de nouvelles personnes qui se
présentent en particulier concernant les
portails des choses comme sa chose qu'on
ne faisait pas jusqu'à présent
et puis naturellement des plantes
quelquefois un petit peu plus rares on a
un rosiéristes qui revenue cette année
on en avait pas les précédentes éditions
enfin les récentes éditions
donc ça les rosiers c'est toujours très
très prisé et il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui savent aller pendant
longtemps ça va dépendre du temps c'est
difficile travail hier de connaître
temps peut on aujourd'hui penser que les
gens puisque quand ils achètent un
billet d'entrée ils peuvent venir autant
le samedi que le dimanche on pense à peu
près avoir 2000 entrées le samedi et
2000 intrigue dimanche et ça rendez vous
plutôt pour les spécialistes ou c'est un
rendez-vous finalement pour tout le
monde non sont les personnes qui aiment
jardiner c'est un rendez-vous qui est
vraiment pour les habitants de la région
qui veulent
au début du printemps relancer leur
jardin et avoir de nouvelles plantations
et c'est pas du tout un salon de
spécialistes c'est un salon pour tout le
monde mais avec des conseils de gens qui
connaissent de d'exposants qui
connaissent très bien leur métier
ça c'est le moment idéal pour planter
c'est le bon moment ça dépend pour quoi
mais pour la majorité des plantations
c'est le bon moment oui elle ordinale
c'est toujours aussi populaire on peut
le dire il semble que la plupart des
habitants ayant en partie amortie un
petit peu l'achat de leur maison
en plus de faciliter en ce moment pour
décorer le jardin on a deux de personnes
qui viennent pour redécorer un jardin
pour refaire un jardin et donc
effectivement c'est un peu plus à la
mode en ce moment et les fonds sont
reversés à une association et également
oui alors le lion's-club collecte ces
fonds pour une de ses actions phares qui
la lutte contre la cécité faut savoir
que le lion ce club avait créé l'école
des chiens guides d'aveuglés et il ya
une école qui vient d'ouvrir juste à
bucca côté qui porte le nom d'un membre
du lions club et 7
cette manifestation par a permis déjà de
financer quatre chiens guides et on
espère bien cette année pouvoir financer
le cinquième chaîne vide c'est-à-dire
vous pensez faire
combien au niveau des fonds que chaque
année nous fait combien on fait à peu
près
entre 9000 et 10000 euros de recettes
qui sont entièrement reversés à cette
association
il faut savoir qu'un chien guide ça
coûte entre 15000 et 20000 euros à peu
près parce qu'un chien il y à sa
naissance son éducation sa nourriture
ses frais vétérinaires le suivi pendant
toute sa vie et puis une chose qui est
très importante aussi la loi comme le
outre à la retraite
donc il ya des familles d'accueil qui de
la retraite des chiens et l'association
sera présente ce week-end là où il
naturellement l'association sera
présente elle a un stand et il y aura
aussi un ou deux non voyants qui sont là
avec leurs chiens guides dont - qui est
un échec dont on a financé la formation
et il y aura également des produits de
terroir ancestral est alors
traditionnellement on s'organise avec
une grande partie sur les produits du
jardin mais les produits jardin on peut
toujours les décliner avec des produits
qui sont
gustatif et on a effectivement un salon
des terroirs qui a à peu près un quart
des exposants est là la plupart sont
vraiment des habitués les gens qui
reviennent depuis longtemps qui ont leur
clientèle et les habitants de la région
attendent attendre ses exposants avec
impatience c'est la 13ème édition aura
une 14e mais bien de répliquer à ceux
déjà signés
c'est toujours le quatrième week-end
d'avril donc la quatrième édition et est
prête
dès lundi on se lance la 14e édition
donc en dvd le 17 merci à vous les
patients ce plateau bon courage pour
l'organisation de cet événement je pense
que c'est pas beaucoup dormir sur les
prochaines nuits pour l'organiser demain
matin 6h du matin ok il ya les exposants
bon courage en tout cas merci on ouvre
après à présent une page cinéma
comme chaque semaine un programmateur
des civils nous présente son coup de
coeur aujourd'hui nous partons signer
cette d'elancourt le responsable du site
et 7 luc beau quand nous présente donc
son coup de coeur alors le coup de coeur
du système du ciné cette semaine c'est
un très beau film qui s'appelle les
ogres troisième long métrage de léa
fehner c'est un film français il faut
signaler
c'est bon ça dure deux ans 24 pour ça
peut paraître long mais on voit pas le
temps passer c'est une très belle
comédie dramatique avec adèle haenel qui
raconte en fait l'histoire d'une troupe
de saltimbanques de gens qui font du
théâtre
alors il ya des égos qui se dispute et
caetera et le retour d'une ancienne
amante et
la venue d'un nouvel enfant a bouleversé
la donne je vous en dis pas plus c'est à
voir en salles chez nous au ciné c'est
de cette semaine un très beau film
français à découvrir
j'en ai marre c'est une histoire de
famille et n'ont pu chanter temps deux
heures je veux que tu sois de nickel à
un jeu comme normaux bourgeois il prend
on passe à présent aux autres sorties de
la semaine dans les salles obscures il
ya du choix à cette semaine alors moi
j'ai bien aimé on retrouve pas mal de
l'univers des malheurs de sophie s'est
pas complètement fidèle mais on retrouve
plutôt les bêtises et effectivement il
ya pas mal d'émotion des moments un
petit peu triste mais il ya aussi
beaucoup de moments rigolos est reflétée
bien les bien-aimés
c'est ce que j'ai bien aimé c'est quand
il se sera étaient entre copines et
c'était bien j'aimais bien
c'était parfait j'ai vu le premier je
m'attendais pas à ce qu'il y ait une
continuité mais ils ont bien
ils ont bien c'est une belle histoire
parce qu'il remonte en arrière 2
de la fin du premier film et j'adorais
ce film parce qu'il est plein de
scénarios c'était vraiment bien les
actions surtout et c'est un très beau
film
c'est une comédie assez léger mais
plutôt sympathique bien interprété par
andré dussollier et ce sympathique c'est
pas inoubliable mais c'est un film
plutôt attachant voilà moi j'ai beaucoup
aimé c'est rigolo c'est bien joué
tous les acteurs sont extra on se régale
c'est la fin de ce statut ce week end
merci d'avoir suivi je vous retrouve à
lundi prochain pour le 7-8 sport a passé
un excellent week-end sur tv fil 78